some not great statistics here in nevada
ranked 50th
for mental health and there's a long
waiting list for autism assessments for
children
yeah there is an organization that's
trying to ease the load here in the
valley bianca holman in our newsroom
this morning to explain good morning to
you bianca
hey good morning alex good morning john
so boys town is filling an important gap
they are increasing access to care for
families who have children with autism
so they have three more child
psychologists at this new facility
and it's a space at the collaboration
center in the southwest part of the
valley
the facility includes a waiting area a
testing area for staff to observe the
child while playing
now prior to testing the clinical
psychologists will obtain all the
necessary background information from
their teachers
parents and doctors
one thing that the pandemic has sort of
taught all of us is that it's okay to go
like this it's okay to raise your hand
and say hey you know we need a little
bit of help we need a bit of extra
support
you know parents have been thrust into
many roles that they haven't
traditionally had
primarily being teachers you know of
their kids and and being you know kind
of overseeing
that from that end so we we've
definitely seen an increase in referrals
to to our services
within boys town nevada and i know that
other local nonprofits have seen the
same thing
and also this new clinic will help
reduce the current 18-month
wait list to receive autism testing
and also the clinic was made possible by
a generous donation from the inglestad
foundation
reporting live in the newsroom bianca
holman 8 news now